what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video titled
mind games that keep a woman interested
it's actually
interesting when i'm like watching these
videos to think if like guys have like
tried or like
succeeded at doing this to me so i'm i'm
about to find out before i start
hit that subscribe button to help a girl
out i'm just
trying to grow on this platform so when
you got a second hit that subscribe
button please
you most like exactly clicked on this
video because you want to know
what can i say what can i do how should
i be acting
to keep a woman interested in me for the
long haul
to keep her coming around and wanting
more question
is he in a long-term relationship like
over five years because more i feel like
we should really only be taking advice
from people
whose position in life you want to be in
but what you have to realize is
in order for this to happen you have to
have something that she
wants and there's a lot of things that
women want from us men
so i'm going to go over five ways you
can keep a woman hooked today
the first way you can keep a woman
interested in you for the long haul
is by having a life outside of her now
we always talk about
purpose and mission and goals but this
is crucial
yes it's really attractive when a guy is
driven
and like works hard and has something
that he's working towards i'd agree when
it comes to keeping a woman
hooked onto you and wanting to see you
over and over again
see what most guys do is they
accommodate and fix their schedule
especially when they like a girl to make
her happy
they try to do things and say well i'm
going to cut off going to the gym
i'm going to cut off my friends i'm
going to cut off working on this project
i'm going to cut off once
to work for overtime and making more
money just to spend time with her
but what that's doing is backfiring
because she's gonna say
man i miss the old you and i'm like baby
what do you mean
i thought everything was going well i'm
doing everything you wanted me to do
who's heard that before who said that
before i i tried to do everything you
want what's wrong
you know in her mind she's thinking
that's not what i wanted you to do
i just wanted you to be you
people lose themselves in relationships
that's definitely
because the reason she dated you was for
you not for someone else so if you're
changing yourself to be with her
like you're not the person she fell in
love with i just want you to continue to
do what you were doing
prior to us getting together because
that's what attracted her to you
you doing what you doing you having a
purpose but when you start cutting down
on your purpose and you try to be with
her who's she going to cheer for
who's she gonna support you're
supporting her
so make sure you have your life in order
and you don't cut off anything
just to appease and make her happy and
comfortable
the second way you can keep a woman
interested
in you and hooked for the long term
is by not revealing how you truly feel
about her
especially in the beginning of any
situation
you're dating you're just got together
you're hanging out having sex
don't expose your hand okay always think
of women
like you're playing poker because she's
always holding her deck and she's doing
what she got to do
to get whatever she wants out of
situation and you have to do the same
see most men think and i've been there
in the past that if you profess your
love you tell her
i love you i care about you and you
write all these poems and
you spill your guts and write long text
messages
that man she's gonna stay with me yeah
that's how logic people think that's how
us
men think but when it comes to women
they're illogical they run out emotions
and they need constant stimulation
so that means she needs to understand i
don't know where this guy stands with me
i don't know
how he feels he's mysterious we're just
hanging out we're hooking up having a
good time
uh does he really like me does he think
about me
is he talking to other women am i on the
am i only girl
is there other women in the picture so
when she starts thinking about all this
stuff
this is what's going to cause her to get
hooked on you
i would disagree i know guys are going
to say i'm so full of [ __ ]
but if a guy like
is playing these games there there just
comes a point where you don't have the
time for it
i'm not say i'm sure there's a reason
why he's giving
these examples out but you have to think
about like what type of women are you
gonna attract
a woman that likes mind games and likes
drama
so that's what i would think also
don't try to commit to her right away
too many guys do this
the sex is good she's cooperating the
vibe is great and then you say man
hey baby i want you to be my girlfriend
listen what does it matter if she
actually is your girlfriend and you say
i want to commit to you
it means nothing because you're not
going to get any other benefits out of
it you're still going to get the same
sex you're still going to get the same
woman she's going to show up
so you actually being in a committed
relationship with that woman you telling
her
and this is why i encourage girls to
withhold on
the sex because
what you don't want to feel used and
you don't want you don't want your body
count to be through the
roof and that like decreases your value
over time to men
and it sucks like that that's how it is
but it just
is and that's why you should really like
be careful who you sleep with
and make sure their intentions are good
because a guy that's just trying to like
hit it and quit it and isn't looking for
a long-term relationship
he's not going to stick around but a guy
that is well
you want to be with her really means
nothing
because it's just the title the only
thing you should be concerned about is
having a good time
so when you do this she can bring up hey
um
do you want to be together and you can
choose hmm
should i hire this woman or should i
just keep her on
90 day probation and say hmm let's just
see how it is
but you don't want to have this one
artist mindset
because when you want to commit to a
woman really fast she's going to think
this guy doesn't have options he doesn't
have a life like that
and women want to be with the guy who
other women want
she wants to wonder hmm does this guy
want to be with me or is he seeing other
women does he sleep with other girls
but it's pretty obvious it's pretty
obvious
which guys other women want and which
guys
other women don't you don't really have
to fake it or do these games so she can
become
more attached to you number three and
this one is
very important underrated as well
most men do not take advantage of the
times that we're in
right now things that are going on
around the world
most people are in the house especially
if you're in a cold weather area
you can say hey let's start a season on
netflix or
hulu or hbo or fire stick whatever the
case may be
and when you start that season make sure
it's interesting and exciting
and make sure it's least five six seven
ten seasons
so that way she can continue to come
back
and want to hang out with you you can
start something
watch maybe two possibly three episodes
when she comes over
you can hang out have some dinner have
some take out and hang out have sex
and after that she goes about her
business then that will keep her
invested in you
because once women watch shows they love
staying consistent with something so
she's not gonna go home and pick up and
watch the show wherever you guys
is this when my boyfriend always wants
to watch movies
left off she's gonna wait around and say
hey when can i see you again so we can
continue where we left off and then you
can invite her over again
watch one or two more episodes three
more episodes
and then hang out hook up and continue
to do it again but you must get women
invested
and not just you but a show a season and
make sure it's something long
don't do like one or two seasons and
then she's like okay well
that's it make sure you're watching
something
that she can think about so then when
she texts you hey what are you up to
you can say oh i'm doing great hey let's
continue
where we left off come on over and
she'll say oh okay
so she'll have something to do hang out
with you and not just have sex
but she'll have a movie or show that she
can continue
to watch with you and invest in number
four
and here's what most men go wrong when
they start dating and seeing a woman
the sex is good they're having fun and
then they're hanging out
one night a week let's say thursday
evening and a couple weeks go by then
she says hey
uh can i come over and see you again
then now it's two nights
out of the week then let's say a couple
months go by then she's over
three nights out of the week and all the
while she's continuing to bring stuff
over
what you need to do is have a boundary
for a woman have some sort of schedule
do not have a woman over your place
no more than one to two nights per week
do you guys these guys do not want
girlfriends
because which is fine you don't have to
but you i can just tell who is target
marketing
what's gonna happen is she's going to
take you for granted she's going to get
bored
she's going to say hmm well this is
getting stale she's going to drift off
to a guy
who she only sees maybe one night a week
okay yeah it sounds crazy
but this is how things are with women
you must keep you a distance because
that's going to cause her to do whatever
she needs to do maybe she wants to see
other guys maybe she wants to do this
but then you can see other women you can
hang out do this you can do that
you can focus on your business in school
but you're not giving her
all that time and energy this is how
arguments and debates start when you're
with a woman
and she just sit down hanging out on
your couch and it's during the day you
guys are sitting down
then guess what she's gonna need that
stimulation so she'll start to pick
fights or arguments
okay this is why less is always more
less time less effort less energy will
keep her
excited and hooked and wanted to come
around and hang around with you more and
more and more
but the more days you give her the more
nights you give her
and you try to have you realize when you
get married
you have to you spend every night
together
so again short-term strategy not a
long-term solution
ever move stuff into this she's going to
take you for granted
unfortunately so limit the time that you
spend
with women this will cause her to want
to see you and get hooked onto you
number five she must prove that she's
not a liability
that she's not an inconvenience or a
headache see what most guys do they get
really excited
they're hanging out with a girl and
they're dating her and
they start treating her and taking her
out all these different places
taking her downtown taking her this
place that place organizing different
events
every single weekend but what you're
doing is you're spoiling her
you're laying a groundwork you're saying
this is how i would treat you and this
the expectation you should have of me
so then you're going to be breaking out
your wallet spinning all this stuff on
her
and then when you don't want to do it
anymore when you just want to have a
night in
she's going to say wait a minute aren't
we supposed to go out
so if you want to keep her hooked keep
the expectations
very low she must earn her right to a
dinner she must
earn her right to outing and by earning
she must
continue to have consistent sex she must
be cooperative she must not be flaky she
must have a good attitude
and you reward her every two to three
months
that's the time window not every two to
three weeks
she must be consistent every two to
three months it's kind of like an
employee
two to three what
so is he saying that you only go on
dates every two to three months or like
are you talking about like expensive
stuff because i would get that it's like
an expensive thing
do what you're supposed to do and then
after that 90 days or after that six
months or a year
you get a raise and that's what it's
going to cause you
to want to continue to work for that
company
you're the company so every two to three
months that's when you take her out
somewhere you both
do something that's fun and then that
goes by another two three months you do
it again
but stop treating her and giving her
raises every week every
weekend and and just say here you go he
gonna give her all these gifts and
prizes and all stuff like that relax
understand you're a company this is a
business that you're operating
and she only gets a raise she only gets
benefits
as long as she continue to show up to
work on time
i i somewhat agree agree with this
you need both people putting effort into
the relationship so if she's not putting
in any effort
why would you spend why would you match
that energy
but but see that at the same time
like i think there's always going to be
times in a long term like marriage where
maybe one person isn't
putting in as much energy as the other
and like you're
you know sometimes like a gesture act of
kindness is something that can really
save or help a relationship
cooperates she does things around the
house she runs errands she washes dishes
whatever she needs to do
but she must continue to show you that
she's a viable
employee that she's reliable she's not
gonna give you problems or issues
this is what's gonna cause her to get
hooked on you because she understands
i gotta work for darius i gotta work for
this guy
in order to get whatever he has
uh this is an interesting video um
there's definitely some tidbits of
information that i can like
see why he would recommend or like i
could see working especially in the
short term
but i'm just a very long term thinker
and i can't imagine
like keeping up and playing those games
for a lifetime it just seems like too
much work
but you let me know in the comments if
you agree or you disagree
what you think i got right and what you
think i got wrong i will talk to you
guys
next time